it's an interesting one it's sort of our
to to get gets processes the same speed
to understand this one you need to
understand what the megahertz or the
gigahertz or the kilohertz here we go
back off are often terahertz processes
they be fast
dunno anyway I died you died Gress we
need to think about what that's actually
describing we
thing that we can describe the speed of
repressor by looking at its gigahertz
rating so 1.6 gear as opposed to is
faster than 1.5 2 gigahertz processor is
faster than 1.6 and so on to an extent
that's true but it only really fits if
you've got the same model of processors
but if you compare different even
different iterations of Intel's Core i7
architecture or say a core i7 compared
to a rice and chip then ambling Rison
chip then it breaks down and it's down
to what the megahertz is describing and
then how the CPU is built inside so the
the megahertz or the gigahertz is
describing how fast the clock which
synchronizes the computer runs I wait to
think about this is if you think about
the conductor of an orchestra
he's keeping time the orchestra's then
playing in time that's what the clock in
a CPU does it keeps track of time of
what's happening and if you think back
to the previous video did about a couple
of years ago on pipelines in a modern
CPU you have a series of steps that goes
through and they're very simple we could
label this is we've got a fetch step a
decode step and an execute step and this
is similar to what the original arm is
CPU had and so in the first clock cycle
of these two colors here we start
fetching the first instruction then in
the second clock cycle we start decoding
that instruction fetching the second
instruction then in the third clock
cycle we actually get around to
executing this one we decode the second
and we start fetching the third and so
on and this goes on
so we then get the fourth or a decoding
the third and we execute the second and
so on this continues providing that we
can actually satisfy things and we don't
get any pipeline stalls this happens as
long as we don't require part of the CPU
this hearsay to be here so for example
that CPU can only access one thing from
memory at a time then we can't fetch and
fetched from memory at the same time in
these stage we get a store watch the
other video for that this moment low
doing more than one thing at time the
answer is yes we are we're trying to
speed up the execution of our CPU and
realizing that actually when we're
executing things we're not using this
but normally so if we spray things up
into a pipeline then we can
have all bits of the CPU happening we
can think about these being synchronized
to the clock we do this bit here in the
first clock cycle this is the second
clock cycle the third clock cycle the
fourth clock cycle and so if we keep
this structure we make a clock cycles
shorter I we run a high and megahertz
speed high gigahertz speed and then
things get faster so this works fine and
if we increase the clock speed then we
can decrease the amount of time that
each of these steps take but there
becomes a limit because these are
implemented in digital logic then after
a while the logic itself will take up a
certain amount of time and we won't be
able to reduce it anymore because
otherwise the clock speed would be
ticking over before we finish running
logic is what's called the propagation
delay in the digital logic so we've got
a minimum amount of time and actually
it'll probably be governed by one of
these steps so there's going to be a
limit on how fast we can get our clock
speed based on the logic but we can get
around that by actually making our
pipeline longer so what we could say is
I say we break it down not into three
steps but into six smaller steps and
they would do parts of what was being
done in here and so on so this one might
fetch just might part decode this might
finish decoding this might get something
from a register and these two might do
part of the execution and so on I'm
making up different things here there's
various ways you can build these things
and in this case we've got one two three
four five six steps so it'll take longer
for our pipeline to get full but when it
does if we can run at full pelt we'll be
able to run faster with a faster clock
speed because each of these steps take
up less time of course the problem is is
if we then get a bubble in our pipeline
then it'll take longer to refill so here
we've got a bubble we've got set at one
or two cycle delay here we'd have a four
or five cycle delay it possible so if
this was say running at wonkiness and
this was at one point to a five cycle
delay would take longer than one cycle
delay here and so on and so what you can
see is that our CPU design the
architecture the way the internal bits
are built has as much influence on how
fast the program runs
the clock speed and increasing the clock
speed but changing the design doesn't
necessarily mean it'll be faster even
though it's running faster now hopefully
you can get it and sometimes you have to
redesign your program to get the best
advantage out of it so the changes in
the architecture have an effect so what
you need to do is design your CPU so
that you try and avoid getting those
bubbles in the pipeline that actually
even though you've got a faster CPU
because we're now executing these
directions on a much quicker basis we
want to keep the pipeline full and so
what you end up doing is designing other
bits of things things like superscalar
architecture which we talked about
before while we can run more than one
instruction at the same time you have
out of order execution where you move
things around to try and avoid the
bubbles and you to do that you rename
registers and have more registers and
things all sorts of things going on you
have a branch predictor which is trying
to make sure that we don't get the
bubbles in the first place by choosing
the right instructions and so on and all
of that can have an influence on how
fast your CPU actually runs the code as
much as this clock speed so the clock
speed does tell you how fast it is but
you can't really use it to compare
between different CPUs of different
types so we can execute that multiply D
up there you think well okay can we do
the other at the same time well no
because we need the result of that as
well so we can then execute the ad down
here before finally and it just fits on
the paper that so we can actually squash
things up and we're gonna save some time